[Music]
my next guest is the co-host of the eric
andre show on adult swim and a comedian
whose stand-up special hannibal burris
animal furnace premieres on comedy
central this sunday at 11 p.m please
welcome the very funny hannibal burris
[Applause]
hello hello everybody hello i lost i
lost my ipad
on a plane that's a modern tragedy
i like the ipad my favorite feature was
reading books
on an ipad because nobody knows what
you're reading i like that privacy i
don't want to know i don't want people
knowing all the stuff i'm reading i was
in the airport bookstore and i saw this
book
the title was o.j simpson is innocent
and i can prove it i said that's
interesting but i'm not buying that book
in public
that's definitely a download right there
what type of phone you have
you yeah
you got android most most people got
androids and iphones or blackberry i get
weirded out when i see people with a
flip phone
yo that's not your real phone right you
just gonna use that phone to make one
call to get somebody murdered then
you're throwing that in the ocean
that's not your real phone you're gonna
order 100 kilos of cocaine you're gonna
stomp that phone and eat the sim card
that's not so real cause that's a real
phone
sometimes when i uh whenever i eat at a
restaurant
i never put the napkin in my lap
i never
put the napkin in my lap and people say
hannibal
why don't you put the napkin in your lap
because i believe in myself
i believe in my ability to not spill
food in my pants because i'm an adult
and i've mastered the art of getting
food from my plate to my mouth without
soiling my jeans you believe in yourself
too and get your life together that's
for babies
believe in yourself
and have confidence believe in yourself
like one of those weird clothing stores
that only have like six shirts in them
so many questions how much do these
shirts cost how long have y'all been
here why is there a dj
why is there a dj but horrible customer
service hey man can i check out these
shirts man i'm spinning right now i
don't care about shirts
i went to this one restaurant i wanted
to order the swordfish but the swordfish
was market price
and i don't know anything about the
swordfish market
so this kind of puts me in a spot
because i don't know whether it's classy
to say to the server hey what's the
swordfish market looking like today
because i don't want to destroy my life
cause it is yo i heard hannibal's living
on the streets now what happened
that damn swordfish market
he kept ordering the swordfish who knew
the swordfish market fluctuated so much
it was 5 000 every time i don't know why
i didn't try the salmon the salmon mark
is very static
i really get into a lot of tv shows i
really get overly entertained like i
watched this show homeland i watched
nine episodes of homeland i got home one
night i wanted to watch the final three
episodes but i was kind of drunk and
nodding out and i was thinking man if i
had some cocaine
i can knock out these last three
episodes
and i think that's the mark of a great
show
if you're willing to pick up a new habit
instead of just going to sleep for a few
hours
like no i need to know what these
fictional characters are up to now
i want to see this play i want to see a
play in new york called sleep no more
and it's not a regular play where you
sit
in the audience and watch people perform
on the stage it's in this five-story
building and actresses they just pop
into any room and start doing a scene
and they leave that room and go and meet
up with actors in another part of the
building and it's i guess they said it
was loosely based on macbeth but i don't
know anything about big back so the
whole experience for me was just getting
drunk and chasing actors around
hey what's going on over here i don't
understand any of this what does this
dance mean but it was a fun time and i
was in this office set by myself
all alone and i farted in that room
but then two actors came into that room
to do a scene and they acted into my
fart cloud
and i conceded it was bothering them but
they had to stay in the scene and power
through
and you know what i was just happy to be
a part of the process
[Applause]
everybody